it's been about more than a week since
the verdict
as you sit here with me now
has it sunk in
how could it
surreal
and
difficult
in part yes
this has been
a long time coming do you stand by
your testimony and your accusations
against johnny depp about abuse of
course to my dying day will stand by
every word of my testimony
the real life drama of the defamation
case between amber heard and her
ex-husband johnny depp captivated
millions of people around the world
abrahar just got exposed johnny you hit
me
this is so cringe
with clips spreading across social media
like wildfire
i think vast majority of this trial was
played out on social media i think that
this trial
is an example of that gone
haywire gone amok and the jury is not
immune to that you think the jury saw it
how could they not i think even the most
well-intentioned juror
it would have been impossible to avoid
this
people online and crowds outside the
courthouse made it clear where they
stood
every single day i passed
for
three four sometimes six blocks city
blocks lined with people holding signs
saying burn the witch
death to
amber after three and a half weeks i
took the stand
and saw just a courtroom packed
full
of captain jack sparrow fans
who were vocal energized can you put
into words
how
that
felt
this was the most humiliating and
horrible thing i've ever been through i
have never felt
more
removed from my own humanity
i i
i felt less than human let's go back to
the the day of the verdict were you
feeling confident
that's a great question
i wish i could say yes to that
i want to say yes to you but it would
it wouldn't be true
even if you think
that i'm lying you still couldn't tell
me
look me in the eye and tell me that you
think on social media there's been a
fair representation do you find that mr
depp has proven all the elements of
defamation
answer yes
after the six-week trial the jury found
her defamed depp in a 2018 washington
post op-ed in which she wrote she was a
public figure representing domestic
abuse she never mentioned her ex-husband
by name
depp denied the abuse allegations in
court heard won just one of three claims
in her countersuit against her
ex-husband
that verdict came less than two years
after a judge ruled against stepp in a
similar case in the uk in which he sued
a british newspaper that called him a
wife beater
there was another trial
handled in with the same dealt with the
same substantive issues that had even
more evidence in in fact mine
my evidence was largely kept out really
important pieces of evidence kept out
done differently handled differently
by a judge instead of a jury
some evidence is admissible in a uk
court that is not admissible in a u.s
court do you think that maybe he just
had better lawyers i will
say his his lawyers did certainly a
better job of distracting the jury from
the real issues for some people
they just were frankly disgusted by the
whole thing and don't have much sympathy
for either one of you
can you understand that
absolutely i would not blame the average
person for looking at this and how it's
been covered
and not think that it is
hollywood brats that they're at their
worse i'd
but what people don't understand is it's
it's actually
so much bigger than that
this is uh
this is not only about
our first amendment right to speak but
here's the thing about the first
amendment the first amendment protects
free speech
it doesn't protect lies that amount to
defamation and that was the issue in the
case yes exactly you can't go into the
free speech does not protect you if you
you know go into a crowded theater and
you scream fire we get the concept of
free speech from the greeks my
understanding of what that means is not
just the freedom to speak
it's a freedom to speak truth to power
but truth is the word yes that was the
issue and that's all i spoke
and i spoke it to power and i paid the
price
in the closing arguments the depth
lawyer said
called your testimony the performance of
a lifetime and said you were acting
what do you say to that
says
the lawyer
for the man who convinced the world he
had scissors for fingers
i'm the performer
i had listened to weeks of testimony
uh
insinuating that or saying quite
directly that
you know i'm a terrible actress
so
i i'm i'm a bit confused how i could be
both the depth team argued that you
were the abuser that you instigated
physical violence did you
i never had to instigate it i responded
to it when you're living in violence and
it becomes
it becomes normal as i testified to
you have to adapt you say you were
responding but there is evidence there
are tapes
in which you acknowledge hitting there
are tapes in which you say i started the
fight
i know much has been made of of these
audio tapes they were
first leaked online after being uh
edited what you would hear in those
clips are not evidence of what was
happening it was evidence of a
negotiation of how to talk about that
with
your abuser but i am looking at a
transcript that says he says you start
physical fights and you say i did start
a physical fight i can't promise you i
won't get physical again
i mean this is in black and white i
understand context
but you're testifying and you're just
telling me today i never started a
physical fight and here you are on tape
saying you did as i testified on the
stand about this is that when your life
is at risk
not only will you take the blame for
things that you shouldn't take the blame
for but when you're in an abusive
dynamic psychologically emotionally and
physically you don't have the resources
that say you or i do with the luxury of
saying hey this is black and white
because it's anything
but when you're living in it but then
there are other times there's another
tape where you're taunting him and
saying oh tell the world johnny depp i a
man the victim of domestic violence 20
second clips or the transcripts of them
are not representative of
even the two hours or the three hours
that those clips are excerpt from could
your side have just put the whole three
hours in then
i'm not a lawyer as i testified to i was
talking in those recordings as a person
an extreme amount of emotional
psychological and physical distress
he said it doesn't never
hit you
he never is that a lie yes it is
what about the witnesses who said they
have seen you
instigate physical violence
i've seen firsthand how people will file
rank
and support the person they depend on
did they all come in and lie in court
i am not here to call any of
these witnesses any names i'm here to
just kind of talk about it from
what it felt like for me as a person who
sat there when i asked his lawyers why
do you think you won and the answer i
got was
because she never took responsibility
for anything
she did in the marriage
i
did do and say horrible
regrettable things throughout my
relationship
i behaved in horrible almost
unrecognizable to myself ways there's so
much i have so much regret i freely and
openly and voluntarily
talked about what i did i i talked about
the horrible language i talked about
being pushed to the extent where i
didn't even know the difference between
you know
right and wrong i
will always
continue to
feel
like i was a part of this like i was the
other half of this relationship because
i was and it was ugly
and could be very beautiful
it was very very toxic
we were awful to each other you know i
made a lot of
a lot of mistakes
a lot of mistakes
but i've always told the truth
you